what was your reaction when you heard
about the allegations against a certain
BBC presenter well obviously they're
very serious and concerning allegations
and that's why I'm pleased that the
culture secretary spoke to the director
of the BBC over the weekend and is
confident that the BBC is investigating
this both rigorously and rapidly I think
that's the right course of action what
would you say to people on social media
indeed some MPS who say they might use
parliamentary privilege to try and name
this presenter look we have an existing
set of laws that govern free speech and
privacy I think it's important that the
BBC conducts this investigation quickly
and rigorously given the concerning and
serious nature of the allegations